est-ce qu'on fait confiance à ce
médicament oui je crois que c'est une
avancée thérapeutique intéressante alors
à nouveau à elle ne remplace pas à pas
le vaccin c'est sale d'accord c'est
quelque chose de complémentaire pour
permettre à se vacciner immunodéprimés
ou fragiles d'éviter d'évoluer vers une
forme grave de la maladie ou à ceux qui
ont décidé malgré toutes les
recommandations de ne pas se faire
vacciner d'avoir une thérapeutique
efficace pour éviter évidemment de son
corps et de magie c'est quand même
tout à fait surtout que c'est un
traitement qui sera pas voie orale elle
doit quand comprimé sûr que l'on va
pouvoir acheter en pharmacie sur
ordonnance évidemment et qui a
finalement très probable en peu d'effets
secondaires donc bientôt les massacres
qu'est ce que le pav l'occident fait
c'est quoi c'est alors c'est un
antiviral en fait c'est une combinaison
de deux anti-viraux donc le premier est
un médicament dit antiprotéases sadique
en fait qui va inhiber le ciseau avec
lequel arrive le virus qui lui permet de
découper les différents composants qui
vont lui permettre de se répliquer et
puis le deuxième est un autre antiviral
qui va empêche en fait empêché la
dégradation par le corps humain du
premier antiviral alors son efficacité
aller contre eux le combiné contre tous
les variants camp alors contre tous les
variants du coc vite connu actuellement
pourquoi parce qu'il s'intéresse à une
protéase qui en fait pour le moment
n'est pas muté d'accord que comme vous
le savez les variants ont
essentiellement des mutations qui
concerne ce qu'on appelle la protéine
spikes à une protéine qui exprimait à la
surface qui permet au virus d'entrer
dans les cellules là c'est une protéase
c'est une protéine qui à l'intérieur du
virus pour le moment qui naquit ne fait
pas encore l'objet de mutations dans les
variantes connues mais évidemment
l'utilisation large de ce médicament
comme d'ailleurs puisque c'est un medic
c'est une un des antiviraux est utilisé
pour traiter le sida et bien pourrait
dans un deuxième temps faire apparaître
des résistances évidente alors ça il
faut le prendre il faut le prendre tout
de suite en fait des cons et qu'on est
on a un test positif on peut comprendre
autrui alors on doit le prendre dans les
trois jours idéalement après le début
des symptômes et donc après avoir fait
un test pour être cieux qu'il s'agit
bien de la coved au maximum dans les
cinq jours à nouveau il ne s'adresse
qu'aux personnes un jour un risque de
faire une forme grave de la maladie
c'est à dire un risque d'être
hospitalisé sinon sinon d'aller en
réanimation ou de décéder sinon il ne
faut pas le principe sinon bah a priori
la collision au sort d'une heure bénigne
pour la majorité des personnes sinon si
on a un petit coup vides et qu on
s'inquiète que ça parce qu'ils imaginent
on voit là on a un petit mot vide on se
dit bon je préfère prendre du pab
l'occident pour être tranquille c'est
pas bon faut pas le prendre non en fait
c'est à dire que pour quelques une
personne qui n'a pas de facteur de
risque a priori ça ne sera pas indiqué
quand même c'est un médicament il peut
avoir des effets secondaires accord
qu'il a un certain coût donc il faut le
réserver aux personnes à risque de
mourir à poil et combien alors pour le
moment je ne connais pas le coup
exactement 5 en fait c'est le
laboratoire avait désaccord et
différents pays en fonction du
pib de chaque pays il va déterminer un
prix c'est ça parce que pfizer a donc
quand même annoncé une tarification
jolie échelonné basée sur le niveau du
revenu de chaque pays afin de garantir
un accès équitable à tous et un prix
abordable c'est à dire qu'il sera moins
cher dans certains pays plutôt que dans
d'autres c'est vrai donc le prix il sera
élevé dans le prix priori il sera
probablement relativement élevé
puisqu'il est seulement il faut
récompenser la recherche qui a permis la
mise aux soins et l'essai thérapeutique
de ceux de ce médicament est ce qu'il
est ce qu'il sera contre indiquée pour
des personnes qui ont des comorbidités
des personnes voilà qui ont goodyear est
ou non au contraire c'est pour ces
personnes là il faudra le dos n'y a pas
d'effet recommandèrent voilà alors par
contre aujourd'hui il sera encore contre
indiqué en tout cas non indiquée en cas
de grossesse ou dallas et comment
d'accord parce que quand même c'est un
médicament dont on connaît pas les
effets sur le bébé
mais à l inverse pour les autres
personnes il sera plutôt indiquer
notamment lorsqu'on est âgé lorsqu'on
est fragile lorsque les immunodéprimés
il sera plutôt indiqué alors il a des
effets secondaires notamment il peut
avoir des interactions avec d'autres
médicaments d'accord devrait être
prudents a été annoncée par canon comme
ça anodin non voilà donc faut surtout
pas imaginer que c'est un sorte de
paracétamol qu'on va prendre lorsqu'on
se sent un peu fébrile en dix ans et
plus là que vient comme des anglais
prennent ça c'est à dire on dit pendant
une période donnée c'est à dire que je
joue bien alors c'est un traitement de
cinq jours quand on va prendre trois
comprimés le matin trois comprimés le
soir pendant cinq jours c'est une boîte
de 30 comprimés qui a deux comprimés qui
correspondent au premier antiviral est
un comprimé qui est aux seconds
antiviral